hey schön dass ihr dabei seid zdf heute
live heute mit diesem thema die
angespannte lage auf den deutschen
intensivstationen auch immer mehr corona
kranke landen dort die meisten davon
ohne geimpft zu sein und wir fragen uns
wie sollen die bereits massiv
überlasteten kliniken das eigentlich
schaffen und haben fragen an den
präsidenten der vereinigung der
intensivmediziner dr gerne und marx und
außerdem noch an krankenpfleger
alexander jorde und wenn ihr fragen oder
kommentare habt könnt ihr jederzeit bei
uns im stream dazu schreiben und
kommentieren oder aber ihr schickt sie
an die jetzt eingeblendete mail adresse
und wir fangen an mit alexander jorde
schönen guten abend schön dass sie sich
heute zeit nehmen
alexander jorde hat vor fünf jahren
seine ausbildung als krankenpfleger
angefangen und hat sich dann auch nicht
abschrecken lassen sondern ist danach im
job geblieben und er kritisiert auch
schon seit anbeginn die missstände in
der pflege und das auch schon mal ganz
öffentlich nämlich 2017 hat er in der
ard wahlarena kanzlerin merkel darauf
angesprochen und das ist also ein thema
was ihnen begleitet herr j sie haben
auch ein buch darüber geschrieben und
sie haben ein jahr am stück jetzt auch
also wirklich mit corona kranken sich um
corona kranke im krankenhaus gekümmert
sind auch jetzt immer wieder auf
intensivstationen eingeteilt und wie
geht es ihnen heute wo die lage wirklich
jetzt gar nicht besser zu sein scheint
als vor einem jahr wie groß ist der
frust
es ist natürlich sehr frustrierend vor
allem auch deswegen weil sich die
debatte gefühlt immer wieder im kreis
dreht auch jetzt liegt der fokus vor
allem auf den impfungen also auch den
aspekten die natürlich die patienten zu
uns bringen und das ist ärgerlich dass
sich viele nicht wissen lassen aber es
werden immer noch beispielsweise die
bayern darüber geführt wie personal
unter grenzen aufzuheben also die
bedingungen die sozusagen festlegen wie
viele patienten maximal betreuten dürfen
und es gibt immer noch keine anreize die
vom staat gesetzt werden dass mehr
personal auf den stationen arbeit
beispielsweise finanzielle anreize über
eine zulage und auch jetzt in den
tarifverhandlungen der länder es
beispielsweise um vergütung der
beschäftigten in den unikliniken geht
sind die bundesländer nicht bereit
bessere löhne für die beschäftigten in
der pflege zu zahlen und das frustriert
sein wenn man dann in den statements
immer wieder hört man würde ja alles für
die pflege tun dabei biss da viel viel
luft nach oben und es ist wenig getan
worden in den letzten jahren und jetzt
sind natürlich dass menschen die jetzt
ungeimpft sind jetzt noch dazu kommen
also und ob die sind jetzt einen teil
des problems natürlich ist es sie haben
es angesprochen noch viel komplexer und
größer aber was macht das mit ihnen wenn
sie sich also dann um menschen kümmern
müssen die also dass dort liegen nicht
geimpft sind das ist ja die mehrzahl
macht sie das auch wütend oder will ja
was was löst das in ihnen aus
es ist natürlich frustrierend weil da
auch viel leid mit verbunden ist und
natürlich ist es unklug von den menschen
die sich nicht impfen lassen aus den
unterschiedlichsten gründen weil sie
dadurch vielleicht ihr leben verlieren
oder ihr leben dann einschränkung haben
werden durch die langen folgen einer
intensivtherapie und andererseits ist es
natürlich für uns auch eine belastung
bei weder durch den höheren
arbeitsaufwand bei mehrwerten mit dem
patienten belegt werden die halt kurbelt
haben die man sonst vielleicht nutzen
müsste für andere patienten das
frustriert alles aber dennoch behandelt
natürlich jeden patienten gleich und
auch sonst gibt es ja patienten die
vielleicht aufgrund eigener fehler im
krankenhaus landen sei es aufgrund von
unfällen noch von von fahrlässigkeiten
aufgrund von lebensnahen falschen
verhalten bei ernährung beim brauchen
bei anderen aspekten da verurteilen wir
die patienten ja auch nicht für ihr
verhalten deswegen ist es aus
medizinisch pflegerische sicht für uns
keinen unterschied werden liegt aber es
ist natürlich trotzdem extrem ärgerlich
und sehr sehr bitter für die menschen
die vielleicht auf propaganda oder auf
viel information reingefallen sind sich
deswegen nicht haben impfen lassen und
dann ein leben nahmen die konsequenzen
dafür tragen müssen oder vielleicht
sogar mit ihrem leben dafür bezahlen
und wir wollen jetzt nun um das mal ganz
klar zu machen auch wie viele betten
sind eigentlich noch frei wie viele sind
belegt und auch wie viele davon sind
dann eigentlich corona patientinnen und
patienten wollen jetzt mal in einem
beitrag da ganz klar auf die fakten und
zahlen gucken ein stück von michael
vollath und thomas concia
und wieder ein neuer höchstwert seit
beginn der pandemie die sieben tage
incidents beträgt
232,1 so das robert-koch-institut
auch die hospitalisierung 's rate steigt
also die zahl derer pro 100.000
einwohner die innerhalb einer woche
wegen corona ins krankenhaus mussten
dieser wert liegt nun bei 4,61
höchstwert war letzten winter knapp 16
konkret bedeutet das aktuell liegen
2739 menschen wegen cupid 19 auf der
intensivstation
im wochenschnitt kommen aktuell jeden
tag etwa 200 corona patientinnen und
patienten hinzu wobei die zahl zuletzt
deutlich stieg und womöglich noch
schneller nach oben gehen wird anfang
des jahres gab es in deutschland noch
rund 26.000 intensivbetten heute sind es
nur noch rund
22.000 also etwa 4.000 weniger der grund
es fehlt an personal und patienten darin
angemessen zu betreuen von den 22.000
betten sind derzeit nur noch
2417 frei der engpass könnte dann bei
steigenden corona zahlen ein kritisches
level erreichen schon jetzt melden mehr
als 600 kliniken dass sie ihre
intensivstationen nur eingeschränkt
betreiben können mehr als 300 weitere
haben den betrieb teilweise
eingeschränkt
der kläger ist und dabei auch mit dem
präsident der vereinigung der
intensivmediziner doktor gerne und marx
schönen guten abend herr marx
guten abend wir haben es gerade im
beitrag gehört also stand jetzt sind
heute nur noch rund 2400 intensivbetten
in deutschland frei herr marx die frage
an sie wie schätzen sie das eine ist die
lage für ganz deutschland so dramatisch
oder können sie das für uns ein bisschen
konkreter einordnen
wir haben schon ein regionale unter
einen regionalen unterschied vorzeichen
im moment besonders angespannt ist die
situation in bayern in sachsen und in
thüringen und auch in ballungsgebieten
wie berlin gestern hat die charité ja
verfügt das überhaupt keine planbaren
operationen mehr durchgeführt werden
sondern nur noch notfall eingriffe und
die versorgung der kogit 19 platzieren
das ist ein massiver
notfall ein schritt einschnitt das muss
man sagen an anderen orten zum beispiel
hier in nrw ist die situation noch
deutlich weniger angespannt das hat
offen gestanden auch was mit der
impfquote zu tun ja in nrw ebene
impfquote von 74% und da gibt es schon
gewisse zusammenhänge jetzt auch mit der
inzidenz und mit der entwicklung in den
letzten tagen und wochen
sie sprechen es gerade an die regionalen
unterschiede und wir haben dazu auch
eine grafik bei uns bereits erfolgte
online und da wollen wir mal auch
gemeinsam darauf schauen dass wir das
ein bisschen besser mal einordnen können
dann bild davon bekommen
so sieht das ganze aus also so viele
intensivbetten sind aktuell belegt und
sie haben es angesprochen also ganz akut
scheint die lage dazu sein in bayern in
hessen sehen wir auch dunkelblaue
bereiche oder beziehungsweise hier in
dem falle genau geht es ja um die
prozent wie viel noch belegt sind also
da wo es dunkelblaues sind dann
besonders viele belegt und sie haben es
angesprochen sind also die
ballungszentren und auch bayern ist da
wohl sehr stark betroffen und darüber
wollen wir jetzt vielleicht auch ein
bisschen sprechen also woran liegt es
dann vielleicht auch dass das jetzt
regional da sehr unterschiedlich ist
können sie das nochmal genauer machen
herr max
es hat sehr viel damit zu tun wie hoch
die impfquote ist weil je mehr menschen
nicht geimpft sind desto leichter
breitet sich das virus aus wir haben es
ja immer noch mit am meisten mit der
sogenannten delta variante zu tun und
dies besonders ansteckend dh wenn ein
mensch alleine bürgern ein bürger
positives und man zb zusammen im
restaurant sitzt und dann werden
entsprechend viele menschen eben auch
angesteckt und das spiegelt sich dann
eben auch in den hohen zahlen in der
hospitalisierung wieder aber eben auch
am ende gibt es eben auch immer einen
bestimmten prozentsatz als schweren
verlaufen und da sehen wir jetzt
bundesweit selbst bei
2739 intensivpatienten dass es etwa der
stand wie vor einem jahr und das das
macht schon sorge wirklich julia braun
fragt sich bei uns bei youtube ins im
stream wie können 20 prozent ungeimpfte
jetzt mehr probleme machen als 100%
ungeimpfte vor einem jahr und ich glaube
das ist ja auch das wo wir hier jetzt
wirklich auch noch viel darüber sprechen
wollen
die frage
wir haben ja vor
wir haben ja wir sehen so ähnlich
entwickeln wie vor einem jahr und man
muss sagen wir hatten ja dann erst einen
teil lockdown im november und
letztendlich dann ein sehr
weitreichenden locker und im dezember
genau so wie auch im frühjahr und das
hat dann eben entsprechend zu dem
rückgang der infektionen geführt und
auch zu den niedrigen instanzen und
letzte nicht uns ja auch einen
entspannten sommer in beiden jahren
sowohl 2020 auf 20 21 beschweren wert
nun ist es eben so wir haben viele
vollständig geimpfte aber es sind eben
auch immer noch mehr als zehn millionen
nicht nicht geimpfte menschen in
deutschland und wir sind eben nicht wie
in dänemark in porto in spanien wo er
etwa zehn prozent mehr geimpfte
bürgerinnen und bürger haben und die
sind wirklich in der wesentlich besseren
situation
und wir haben uns ja jetzt auch gerade
auf der karte gesehen es gibt also
wirklich auf bundesländer da scheint die
lage sehr dramatisch zu seinen bayern
ruft erneut den katastrophenfall aus im
bezug auf corona heute in mehr als der
hälfte der bayerischen kreise und
größeren städten sind nur noch weniger
als zehn prozent der intensivbetten frei
das heißt natürlich auch für all die
menschen die dort auf den stationen
arbeiten eine enorme belastung und die
frage an sie herr jorde kommt jetzt hier
auch aus dem stream ich habe sie eben
gerade noch gesehen und zwar hier bei
youtube gab es die fragen jetzt ist sie
mir weggerutscht mensch das gibt es doch
gar nicht ich kann sie jetzt nur noch
also formulieren und wiedergeben die
frage war hier von florian a er fragt
sich woher nehmt ihr die kraft rund um
die uhr und doppelschichten das alles
durchzuhalten
das ist natürlich eine gute frage es ist
allerdings auch so dass viele diese
kraft nicht mehr haben und das sieht man
eben auch daran dass die kapazitäten auf
den intensivstationen zurückgegangen
sind es war ja auch manchmal in
talkshows und wo anders formulierte
design betten abgebaut worden das
widerspricht der realität also die
betten werden nicht aktiv abgebaut
sondern es liegt einfach daran dass
nicht mehr ausreichend personal
vorhanden ist um diese betten zu
betreiben und ich kenne einige personen
die auch nach 20 jahren berufserfahrung
sich jetzt final dazu entschieden haben
den beruf zu verlassen viele haben auch
ihre arbeitszeit reduzieren die
krankenstände steigen immer weiter in
vielen kliniken sind die krankenstände
auch hoch und die kräfte fehlen
irgendwann dann auch natürlich gibt es
viele kolleginnen und kollegen die
weiter gut durchhalten aber alles hat
irgendwann ein ende und irgendwann sind
auch unsere kräfte erschöpft und was man
ja nicht vergessen darf das geht
manchmal etwas unter in der medialen
berichterstattung auch so wie jetzt die
fragestellungen in talkshows und den
anderen formaten immer aufgebaut sind es
geht nicht darum dass nach corona alles
wieder gut ist also selbst wenn corona
jetzt weg wäre ja wer in vielen kliniken
die überbelastung bei weitem noch nicht
weg also wir hatten auch schon vor
kroner die situation dass an vielen
kliniken betten auf intensivstationen
gesperrt worden es gab auch schon fort
corona diese tour und beispielsweise
auch das c7 medizinerin und
intensivmediziner sich hingestellt haben
und gesagt haben die versorgung ist
eingeschränkt gerade wenn es eine sehr
spezielle behandlung wie zum beispiel
kinder intensiv medizin oder in anderen
bereichen da gibt das würde da gab es
teilweise schon einschränkungen auch vor
krone neben pflegepersonal gefehlt hat
und das wird sich nach grüner noch
weiter verschärfen das heißt bei vielen
liegen die nerven blank und die kräfte
schwinden wirklich
jetzt treffen sich morgen spd grüne fdp
wollen darüber sprechen wie die pandemie
auf ein bisschen besser in den griff zu
bekommen ist das würde ja auch teilweise
zumindest vielleicht dazu beitragen dass
die situation sich entspannt aber über
die anderen gründe sprechen wir auch
gleich noch die frage an sie herr marx
also was brauchst dann für see für eine
klinik jetzt aus der politik also
wirklich auch an jetzt akuter schneller
hilfe dass die situation sich vielleicht
entspannen konnten könnte
nun lassen sie sind normal mit dem
pflegepersonal anfang weil das ist für
mich ein besonders großer und wichtiger
punkt und wir haben irgendwie
jordanischen angesprochen das thema ist
nicht neu und das ist auch nicht nur
pandemie bedingt der man es vorher der
partie auch schon darum gekümmert aber
ins gehören jetzt auch in den 22 monaten
der pandemie sehr deutlich auch gesagt
was wir erwarten von der politik an
maßnahmen an konkreten maßnahmen um ins
soll unser pflegepersonal zu entlasten
und auch wertzuschätzen wir haben im
märz zusammen mit der deutschen
gesellschaft für fachkrankenpfleger dgf
1 1 ein potpourri einem blumenstrauß
sondern wirklich ganz vielen konkreten
maßnahmen aufgeschrieben und mit dem
bundesbeauftragten für pflege herrn
staatssekretär westerfellhaus auch
veröffentlicht presseschau wir waren in
der gesundheitsministerkonferenz
aber es ist nichts passiert wir haben
danach eine
pflege petition auch noch mal
herausgebracht also uns wirklich
kontinuierlich gekümmert versucht
kontinuierlich laut deutlich zu sagen
was wir von der politik erwarten auch
einen finanziellen anreiz inkompetenz
arbeiter und ein psychologischer
unterstützung und zwar auch nicht nur
für die pandemie sondern auch darüber
hinaus weil ich bin ganz schnell an
johann ich mache mir besonders große
sorgen um die zeit nach der pandemie wir
haben zwei millionen intensivpatienten
in deutschland jedes jahr zu versorgen
und dafür brauchen sie eben viele
menschen krankenpflegerinnen und
-pfleger physiotherapeuten
ergotherapeuten psychologen natürlich
auch ärztinnen und ärzte und alle die
fühlen sich im moment
wirklich nicht gut unterstützt und das
ist da sind jetzt wirklich dringend
maßnahmen erforderlich und das erhoffe
ich mir jetzt in der neuen
legislaturperiode von der neuen
bundesregierung
jetzt konkrete auf die strukturellen
probleme und auch die maßnahmen kommen
wir gleich noch zu sprechen aber herr
jorde vorab noch die frage auch an sie
selbst sind spd-mitglied aber sie haben
bei twitter jetzt in den letzten tagen
einen inzwischen gelöschten tweet von
fdp generalsekretär volker wissing
kritisiert weil er sagte dem
handelsblatt also eine überbelastung des
gesundheitssystems sehe er nicht jetzt
haben wir das ja hier schon angesprochen
dass das ihrer meinung nach natürlich
nicht der fall ist was sehen sie für
chancen also das jetzt ihre hilferufe
vielleicht auch mal gehört werden jetzt
bei einer möglichen neuen regierung die
dann auch bei zustande kommt
es ist natürlich so dass ich wie alle
anderen auch relativ wenig mitbekommen
was dort in den koalitionsgesprächen
jetzt genau inhaltlich verhandelt wird
da bin ich sehr gespannt was dort im
themenbereich gesundheit und pflege
rauskommt sowohl grüne als auch spd im
wahlkampf einen großen wert auf die
pflege gelegt und da gab es auch gute
vorschläge beispielsweise bessere
personalbemessung
änderungen an der finanzierungsstruktur
beispielsweise die grünen haben eine 35
stunden woche ins gespräch gebracht ich
glaube ich in nordrhein westfalen
schlägt es auch die spd fraktion im
landtag vor also da gibt es vorschläge
die in eine richtung gehen die den beruf
attraktiver machen durch geringere
arbeitszeit durch bessere entlohnung und
andere maßnahmen in eine vernünftige
oder adäquate personalbemessung und da
bin ich eben sehr gespannt darauf was da
rauskommt nur kann man das jetzt leider
noch gar nicht beurteilen und zu dem
tweet von herrn blessing muss man dann
einfach an der sogar schreibt also die
banken hätten eine überbelastung der
weisheit wirklich nicht wovon er spricht
weil diese über belastungen gab es vor
krone und wird es auch nachgucken
ergeben und solche aussagen mal eben zu
tätigen das ist wirklich fahrlässig und
ich finde es unverantwortlich und auch
respektlos gegenüber den beschäftigten
die diese bedingungen vorfinden wie sie
sind und das wird dem nicht gerecht
die frage an sie beide also aus der
politik kamen auch immer wieder der ja
der vorschlag die pflegepersonal
untergrenze in zukunft jetzt für diese
situation aufheben zu wollen vielleicht
zuerst an sie herr marx also was würde
das denn genau für sie bedeuten und was
würde das an der situation ändern
nun ist es ja so die einführung der
pflege können personal untergrenzen
hatte er einen grund und zwar die die
überbelastung zu reduzieren dass
sozusagen das spreizen unsere
pflegekräfte
auf viele patienten zu reduzieren und
die notwendige personal was die
notwendige zeit für jeden pflegenden für
die schwerkranken patienten hier auch
klar zu regeln und es macht überhaupt
keinen sinn in dieser situation wo
sowieso schon alle unglaublich
müde und erschöpft sind nach 22 monaten
pandemie jetzt auch noch die personal
unter grenzen aufzuheben und die
belastungen noch deutlicher zu steigern
für diejenigen die bisher durch gehalten
haben das führt nur dazu dass noch mehr
menschen dem ufer lassen werden oder
noch weiter reduzieren werden das ist
überhaupt keine lösung wenn wir mehr
personal benötigen jetzt in dieser akku
situation wenn es doch weiter jetzt in
diese diese situation sich noch weiter
verschärft was ja durchaus passieren
kann dann müssen wir eben personal aus
anderen bereichen auf die intensiv
bereiche verschieben was sicherlich auch
nicht gerade optimal ist aber immer noch
besser als wenn die patienten unversorgt
bleiben aber ganz bestimmt macht es
keinen sinn und so wichtigen intensiv
pflegekräfte hier noch weiter zu
belasten das ist überhaupt keine lösung
sie beide haben auch schon die
finanziellen aspekte und anreize
angesprochen und auch hier um dass man
ein bisschen konkreter zu machen haben
wir einen beitrag von johanna sagt
meister und laura rosinus
applaus für alle helferinnen und helfer
in alten und pflegeheimen in
krankenhäusern kollektives klatschen
besonders am beginn der pandemie aber
wie sieht die finanzielle anerkennung
aus wie viel ist der politik die
mehrarbeit wert schon im mai 2020
beschloss der bundestag eine corona
prämie bis zu 1500 euro allerdings nur
für beschäftigte in alten und
pflegeheimen
im september 2020 gab es dann auch hilfe
für krankenhäuser an sie sollen
insgesamt 100 millionen euro gehen und
zwar an solche die besonders viele
kurven 19 patienten behandelt haben die
länder konnten die summe aufstocken
das heißt bis zu 1000 euro pro kopf für
pflege und klinikpersonal gezahlt wurde
aber nach einem verteilungsschlüssel
heißt nicht alle bekamen geld
frühjahr
2021 der versuch nachzubessern corona
prämie 2.0 pflegekräfte aus rund 1000
krankenhäusern erhalten eine weitere
prämie dafür werden insgesamt 450
millionen euro vom bund bereitgestellt
das heißt pro kopf bis zu 1500 euro aber
auch hier wieder nicht für alle die
zahlungen hängen davon ab wie viele
kurven 19 patienten 2020 am jeweiligen
krankenhausstandort behandelt wurden
also haben die prämien geholfen eine
aktuelle umfrage sagten fast drei
viertel der deutschen krankenhäuser
haben seit ende 2020 intensiv
pflegekräfte gekündigt die station
gewechselt oder ihre arbeitszeit
reduziert deshalb sagt der deutsche
berufsverband für pflegeberufe applaus
weitere prämien all das helfe nicht
nötig sei eine bessere bezahlung und
zwar dauerhaft
was ist es darüber hinaus noch was es
braucht um die menschen wirklich da im
job zu halten also so viele gehen raus
was brauchst um diesen job wirklich dann
noch attraktiver zu machen
oder wird es ganz viele stellen an denen
man schrauben müsste das hängt natürlich
beim gehalt und bei den
arbeitsbedingungen an ich glaube das
sind die härtesten faktoren die dafür
sorgen dass eben viele menschen den
beruf verlassen es geht ja nicht nur
darum mehr menschen dafür zu gewinnen
sich überhaupt für den beruf zu
entscheiden sondern vor allem menschen
in dem beruf zu halten und auch zurück
zu gewinnen weil die verweildauer im
pflegeberuf liegt im schnitt zwischen
sieben und acht jahren das ist eine der
kürzesten verweildauern in berufen das
heißt menschen entscheiden sich sehr
früh dafür den beruf wieder zu verlassen
und da muss man eben gegensteuern das
heißt wir brauchen wie zb mit diesem
personal untergrenzen die eigentlich nur
ein minimum setzen sollen aber wir
brauchen wir mehr gesetzliche vorgaben
die auch strikt eingehalten werden
müssen wie viele patienten von einer
pflegefachkraft betreut werden dass das
deutlich weniger wird dann hat man mehr
zeit für die patienten kann sich frei
entfalten bei der arbeit man kann auch
das umsetzen was man mal in der
ausbildung gelernt habe dass es sei gar
nicht möglich weil man nur noch den
notstand verwaltet das sind so die
harten faktoren aber dann gibt es auch
andere dinge die sich ändern müssen
damit dieser beruf auch gerade für junge
menschen die beispielsweise in abitur
haben auch interessant wird nämlich mehr
fort entwicklungsmöglichkeiten wir
müssen mehr möglichkeiten für
pflegeberufe schaffen die man sich auch
außerhalb der kliniken oder in den
kliniken auf andere art und weise
entwickeln kann und beschäftigen kann
das gibt es in fast allen ländern in der
in der westlichen welt gibt es noch viel
mehr möglichkeiten es gibt viele
spezialisierte pflegekräfte die in den
krankenhäusern besondere aufgaben
übernehmen es gibt dinge wie community
health nase ist also kommen pflegekräfte
die sozusagen auch in der ambulanten
struktur viel mehr aufgaben übernehmen
und lotsen funktionen erhalten es gibt
schulen als es in anderen ländern also
pflegekräfte die an schulen arbeiten
dann dort wichtige aufgaben übernehmen
das heißt es gibt ein viel breiteres
aufgabenprofil viel mehr kompetenzen
viel mehr dinge die man machen kann ist
jetzt natürlich weit gefasst aber es
gibt viele möglichkeiten wie man den
beruf generell attraktiver gestalten
kann aber um es wirklich noch mal klar
zu sagen die harten fakten sind
arbeitsbedingungen das heißt wie lange
muss ich arbeiten wir brauchen eine
niedrigere wochenarbeitszeit von 35
stunden wir brauchen ein höheres
einstiegsgehalt der dbfk es wurde eben
im beitrag erwähnt fordert 4000 euro
einstiegsgehalt für pflegefachkräfte und
wir brauchen personalbemessung die
wirklich klar macht wie viele patienten
dürfen von einer pflegekraft betreut
werden und das muss dann auch
eingehalten werden von den
krankenhäusern und wenn es nicht
eingehalten wird entsprechend auch
bestraft werden das sind sozusagen die
faktoren die wirklich dazu beitragen
dass menschen sich dann entscheiden dass
sie aus dem beruf raus gehen weil es
nicht passt zu wenig geld für zu viel
belastung
herr professor mag sie müssen gleich
weiter sie habe einen anschlusstermin
aber die letzte frage noch an sie bevor
ich sie verabschiede würden sie jetzt
noch was anschließend wenn der bundestag
der morgen morgen berät an jetzt ganz
konkreten maßnahmen die sie also
brauchen damit sich die situation für
sie und all ihre beschäftigten
verbessert
ja ich glaube ich mach mal auf
neudeutsch die antwort beginn der
antwort hervor was wir müssen uns
wirklich um die menschen die sich um die
schwer kranke kümmern mehr kümmern wir
müssen wirklich sehen und ja das schon
gut angefangen aber wir müssen wir sehen
dass wir die technische und digitale
möglichkeiten ausschöpfen die ist ja
schon gibt um zum beispiel auch diesen
dokumentationsaufwand die ganz viel zeit
der intensivmedizinischen teams
verbringen diese an computern irgendwer
täters zu dokumentieren hier muss man
glaube ich auch intelligente lösungen
finden und neben der bezahlung ist auch
immer ein punkt wenn menschen krank
werden in der pflege bei den ärzten das
andere einspringen müssen und oft das
einzige freie wochenende sozusagen dann
doch wieder in der klinik verbracht hier
sind wir auch gefordert kreative modelle
zu gestalten letztendlich bedeutet das
mehr personaleinsatz
für diesen wichtigen bereich in der
medizin der glaube ich in der zukunft
noch immer wichtiger wird es geht also
auch um und leistung vielleicht
robotische assistenz um den auch diese
körperliche anstrengungen zu reduzieren
es gibt eine ganze menge möglichkeiten
und wir müssen jetzt einfach mal
anfangen und das wird ein ganz wichtiges
signal auch in dieser notsituation in
der vierten welle und wenn ich das
vielleicht noch sagen darf
mal abgesehen auch von den intensiven
medizinischen teams oder überhaupt in
krankenhauspersonal es geht jetzt
wirklich darum patienten zu schützen
maßnahmen zu treffen dass wir unser
personal boostern konsequent in den
krankenhäusern in den pflegeheimen dass
wir uns auch eine test strategie
überlegen gemeinsam mit der politik um
eben auch ausbrüche impft durchbrüche
auch bei unserem personal möglichst früh
zu erkennen und es geht letztendlich
darum und das hat jeder bürgerin jeder
bürger wirklich einer hand wir müssen
uns jetzt wirklich klug und vorsichtig
verhalten um eben dieses
infektionsgeschehen zu stoppen das heißt
auch letztendlich dass wir große
menschenansammlung wahrscheinlich eher
meinen sollten jetzt in diesen kalten
jahreszeiten vielen maske tragen in den
innenräumen viel lüften abstand halten
die gene regel anhören das ist der und
so je mehr menschen sich impfen und
durch das impfen überzeugen lassen
spektive die eltern insbesondere buch
sein lassen und alle anderen nach sechs
monaten auch das ist der weg um die
pandemie zu bewältigen war ich glaube
das ist unser größter wunsch dass wir
möglichst schnell jetzt hier in eine
situation kommen wir wirklich sagen wir
haben die pandemie gemeinsam bewältigt
heißt es auch eine impfpflicht ja oder
nein also für jetzt quasi alle
davon halte ich und auch die divi
insgesamt nichts ich setze da eher auf
überzeugung
und es nützt auch ein zum viele zb im
krankenhausbetrieb ins wurde auf der
intensivstation haben wir eine
unglaublich hohe impfquote war natürlich
alle sehen wohin es führen kann das hat
er ja schon ausgeführt und seinen ersten
beitrag wohin es führt wenn
menschen sich nicht impfen lassen und
wir haben viele nicht geimpfte auch
verloren und ich muss sagen also dass
auch nach vielen vielen berufsjahren das
nennt man echt mit nach hause wenn
menschen die mitten im leben stehen die
familien haben ancona virus an geholt 19
versterben die wir nicht zurück ins
leben bringen konnten dass
das ist schwer
vielen dank herr professor dr marx für
jetzt wirklich auf diese eindrücklichen
schilderung und ihnen noch einen schönen
abend danke
ich danke ihnen
mit herrn jorde dürfen wir noch weiter
ein bisschen sprechen es gibt ja auch
ganz konkret jetzt eine frage auch an
sieben stream julia braun bei youtube
möchte gerne wissen herr jorde sind sie
für eine allgemeine impfpflicht
ich sehe dass nämlich hier profis von
marx ich finds halt schwierig da so
einzugreifen und ich kann es mir auch
nicht vorstellen das lässt sich
natürlich immer leicht formulieren das
thema endlich die frage ist aber wie
sollte die umsetzung aussehen also soll
dann jemand mit gewalt dazu gezwungen
werden wie impfen zu lassen also das
kann ich mir tatsächlich irgendwie
schlecht vorstellen ich will tatsächlich
schöne viel striktere zweig umsetzung
das ist natürlich auch eine art von
druck auf die impfgegner oder auf
diejenigen die sich impfen lassen
möchten aber eben in direkter das heißt
es wird trotzdem niemand gezwungen aber
dann muss man eben damit klarkommen dass
man eben einen bestimmten
gesellschaftlichen aktivitäten nicht
mehr teilnehmen kann das heißt dass man
viele dinge auf zwei gestellt viele sind
es ja schon aber dass man eben
veranstaltung oder wählen die jetzt
nicht zum zum zum überleben wichtig sind
also zum beispiel lebensmittelläden
jetzt nicht aber andere leben dass es
den einfacher gemacht wird oder sogar
aufnahmen gemacht werden dass die
beispielsweise eine zwei die regelung
haben weil das risiko wenn man zweifach
geimpft ist oder genesen ist nun mal
wesentlich geringer ist also wirklich
wesentlich geringer schwer zu erkranken
und ich glaube dass wir tatsächlich der
bessere weg also von der impfpflicht
halte ich auch nichts und von der
impfpflicht für besondere berufsgruppen
halte ich noch viel weniger weil das
würde auch dem grundsatz dass alle
menschen vor dem gesetz gleichen klar
widersprechen dass dinge die mich immer
ein bisschen auch wenn dieses ja dass
das thema aufgebaut wird pflegekräfte
sollten nebenpflicht bekommen bei uns
sind glaube ich wesentlich mehr menschen
geimpft als in der gesamtgesellschaft
und was er auch jetzt immer wieder
diskutiert wird ist die die testung die
kostenlosen testung vielleicht
zurückzubringen wieder mehr zu testen
ist bestellt sich die frage hier zum
beispiel auch king ling bei youtube
fragt sich warum müssen sich geimpfte
nicht testen lassen obwohl sie
nachweislich das virus verbreiten können
ich meine einen punkt haben sie gerade
ja auch angesprochen vielleicht das
jetzt aber nochmal genauer machen also
wie sieht das aus mit den geimpften wie
viele sind dann vielleicht auch von den
geimpften bei ihnen auf stationen ist
das bei denen also dann alles viel
schwächer dass sie das vielleicht noch
mal konkreter machen
also ich finde schon dass wir die tests
wieder kostenlos machen sollten bin ich
schon und dass jeder jederzeit die
möglichkeit haben sollte sich testen zu
lassen das finde ich ist der falsche
anreiz zu sagen wir machen die test
jetzt teuer und damit wollen wir die
leute zur impfung bringen ich finde aber
wenn ich jetzt beispielsweise auf eine
veranstaltung die wo ich weiß ich bin
selber doppelt oder vielleicht bei
dreifach geimpft und um mich herum sind
nur menschen die alle auch doppelt
geimpft sind oder eben genesen sind dank
das durchaus sein dass jemand des
niveaus gerade mit sich trägt
dass aber die gefahr mich da jetzt
anzustecken oder einen schweren verlauf
zu bekommen äußerst wirklich äußerst
gering ist deshalb finde ich es da jetzt
nicht so relevant aber wenn man eben
auch eine veranstaltung mit 3g
beispielsweise ist oder an personen sind
die sich getestet haben aber die nicht
geimpft sind nicht genesen sind die
natürlich diese erkrankungen bekommen
dann laufen sie halt gefahr schwer zu
erkranken das ist dann aber ein risiko
dass die person für sich bewusst
eingehen wenn ich doppelt geimpft dann
trage ich dieses risiko fast nicht mehr
mit mehr und deswegen bin ich halt
deutlich mehr für 2g als für eine
impfpflicht und bin aber trotzdem dass
man die tests auch kostenlos machen
sollte weil das finde ich ist der
falsche anreiz
es gibt noch mehrere fragen stehen und
zwar jetzt auch wieder ganz allgemein
eher zu den problemen für eine in der
pflege und da gibt es eine frage ich
suche sie gerade stefan reichert bei
youtube haben es vorhin angesprochen
dass auch die bezahlung ein thema ist
und er möchte gerne wissen was kann man
denn als pflegekraft verdienen dann
kommt das vielleicht auch mal in die
relation warum das vielleicht auch
problematisch ist können sie das
beantworten ja also das ist eine sehr
schwierige frage weil es sehr darauf
ankommt in welchem bereich man arbeite
ich sage mal wenn man jetzt zum beispiel
auf einer intensivstation arbeitet
verdient man beispielsweise mehr in der
regel als wenn man auf einer normalen
station im krankenhaus arbeitet wenn man
für einen öffentlichen arbeitgeber
arbeitet also zum beispiel in einem
landeskrankenhaus oder in einem
kartenhaus das dem tv wg angehört und in
der regel auch den kirchen die bezahlen
in der regel besser als beispielsweise
jetzt bei privaten kliniken nehmen wir
beispielsweise helios oder andere große
ketten genauso ist es auch in der
altenpflege wo gerne sei wiederum
schlechter bezahlt wird als in der
krankenpflege usa überhaupt wieder
unterschiede gibt zwischen kirchlichen
trägern privaten träger an öffentlichen
trägern genau das gleiche gilt für die
ambulante pflege wohnen der regel noch
mal wieder um schlechter bezahlt wird
das heißt in der pflege ist es sehr sehr
breit aufgefächert was die
verdienstmöglichkeiten angeht dann kommt
es auch noch auf die qualifizierung an
mit einem normalen berufsabschluss habe
ich noch eine weiterbildung als intensiv
pflegekraft oder bin ich kann oder habe
ich die pflegehelfer oder
pflegeassistenten ausbildung das macht
einen großen unterschied
ungefähr kann man sagen dass das
einstiegsgehalt wenn man jetzt einen
öffentlichen arbeitgeber nimmt im
schnitt zwischen zweieinhalb 1000 und
3000 euro brutto ungefähr liegt da
werden viele sagen und das ist auch mal
schwierig in der argumentation
das ist aber schon ein ausbildungsberuf
schon ganz schön gut viele vergessen
aber auch dass diese ausbildungsberufen
sehr hohen theoretischen umfang hat
einen wesentlich höheren umfang als
viele andere ausbildung und dass die
verantwortung die man auch gleich zu
beginn in den beruf trägt eine sehr sehr
hohe ist und dass viele tätigkeiten wie
beispielsweise vor allem auf der
intensivstation als pflegefachpersonen
übernehmen und gar nicht uns zugeordnet
werden von der gesellschaft viele haben
dann ganz falsches bild auch von dem was
wir machen die denken die arbeiten fiel
auf zuweisung viel als assistenz dabei
übernehmen wir auch viel
selbstverantwortung wenn ich jetzt
beispielsweise an meine zeit auf der
intensivstation denkt oder dann wenn ich
auf intensivstationen arbeitet dann ist
es so ich verstehe auch selber die
beatmung ich analysiere auch selber gut
gas analysen und schaue mir das an und
ich muss viele medikamente verabreichen
ich kraken hohe verantwortung und ein
kleiner fehler eine kleine
unaufmerksamkeit gerade in den stress
kann durchaus auch schwerwiegende
konsequenzen bis hin zum tod für die
patienten haben und auch das sind
aspekte zusammen mit der psychischen und
körperlichen belastung man ist viel mit
tod viel mitleid konfrontiert man kann
sich selber bei der arbeit anstecken man
kann auch dabei versterben das sind eben
faktoren die bei der bezahlung auch eine
rolle spielen müssen und deswegen ist
eben diese forderung von gfk nach einer
forderung von 4000 euro brutto was netto
danach unter 3000 ungefähr werden finde
ich eine adäquate forderung vor allem
weil uns auch einst bewusst machen
müssen dann müssen wir diesen hebel
nicht schaffen mehr pflegekräfte oder
mehr für den beruf zu gewinnen dann
bekommen wir eine ernsthafte
versorgungsnotlage in den nächsten
jahrzehnten oder im nächsten jahrzehnt
weil wir diese positionen die wir jetzt
zog ohne haben diese diskussion die wir
jetzt führen in den nächsten jahren noch
viel intensiver führen werden müssen
weil wenn man sich umschaut auf den
stationen dort sind viele aus der baby
boomer generation die demnächst in rente
gehen und dann in zehn zwanzig jahren
auch immer öfter ins krankenhaus werden
kommen müssen und es fehlt einfach der
nachwuchs auf den stationen weil eben
viele auch sehr früh aus dem beruf
wieder rausgehen und sagen bei vw in der
industrie oder woanders da kann ich das
geld wesentlich leichter verdienen und
da habe ich dann am wochenende auch bei
mir ist es denn aktuell in dieser jetzt
zugespitzten situation haben sie immer
genug zeit für ihre patientinnen und
patienten
es ist eine schwierige frage das ist
auch außerhalb von kone genau so dass
man das nie sagen kann es gibt durchaus
auch schichten da hat man die zeit und
kann alles machen das schafft man alles
aber es gibt auch schichten wo notfälle
kommen wo beispielsweise werden die mir
doch patient von draußen von der straße
sozusagen auf die station kommt das
bindet dann gleich mehrere pflegekräfte
das sind sehr arbeitsintensive schichten
dann und da bleibt natürlich einiges auf
der strecke und das ist eben auch das
was man verstehen muss bei der besetzung
einer intensivstation wir können nicht
von der durchschnittlichen lage ausgehen
wir müssen immer von den situationen
ausgehen wo notfälle passieren und es
ist beispielsweise auch so die patienten
die korona patienten liegen auch in
zimmern da muss man sich vorher erstmal
einklagen jp maske aufsetzen einen
kittel anziehen der haube aufziehen wie
sie aufziehen es dauert alles zeit wenn
dann beispielsweise notfälle sind das
sind alles faktoren die man mit
einberechnen muss und wenn man dann
beispielsweise nachts auch mal drei
patienten betreut oder in vielen
kliniken ist es leider auch so dass auch
nachts mehr als drei patienten betreut
werden und auch tagsüber teilweise drei
oder mehr patienten betreut werden
gerade dann wenn auch diese personal und
ergänzen mal nicht gegolten haben
dann sind das eben situationen wo man
natürlich abstriche machen muss und es
ist auch statistisch nachgewiesen gerade
wenn man mehr als zwei patienten auf
eine intensivstation betreut dann steigt
auch die wahrscheinlichkeit dass eine
dieser patienten zerstört
also es ist wirklich auch in glatt an
wenn man zu wenig pflegepersonal gehört
habe
es gibt zum schluss hier noch eine frage
bei youtube von newco tt kann man das
krankenhauspersonal irgendwie
unterstützen kann man sie herr jordan
irgendwie unterstützen als normaler
mensch
das ist eine schwierige frage wald
tatsächlich kommt es auch darauf an
vielleicht schaut ja auch der eine oder
andere pflegekraft hierzu dass wir uns
eigentlich besser organisieren also
natürlich kommt es immer auch
unterstützung aus der gesellschafter an
die besten unterstützt im moment
tatsächlich einfach sich impfen zu
lassen
aber das zählt auch dazu beispielsweise
bei wahlen zu schauen welche parteien
setzen sich dafür ein und natürlich
haben alle parteien in den letzten 20
jahren mal mit regiert und alle haben am
gesundheitssystem bisschen
verschlimmbessert und da ist jetzt
niemand der sich da besonders positiv
herausgehoben hat aber es gibt doch
immer noch unterschiede zwischen den
parteien in den programmen die man
berücksichtigen kann man kann sich mit
pflegekräften solidarisieren die
streiken man kann das unterstützen aber
am ende kommt es tatsächlich auf uns
selbst an dass wir uns besser
organisieren dass wir beispielsweise
jetzt in der tarifrunde der länder das
heißt moment wenn ihr die tarifverträge
gelangt ist beschäftigten wald wo es
auch um die beschäftigten an den
unikliniken geht da kommt es darauf an
dass wir uns als pflegekräfte besser
organisieren dass wir streiken dass wir
uns für unsere rechte und für unsere
arbeitsbedingungen und gehälter
einsetzen und es kommt jetzt vor allem
auch auf die politik an dass die ihre
versprechen aus dem wahlkampf wahr macht
nämlich die situation in der pflege zu
verbessern
und da sind wir sehr gespannt was das
künftig für sie ändert was dabei
herauskommen vielen dank für heute abend
für den moment herr jordan vielen dank
und natürlich auch vielen dank an euch
für euer interesse für eure vielen
fragen und kommentare ich habe versucht
so viele wie möglich davon aufzunehmen
ich bin mir aber sicher das thema wird
ja uns auch nicht hier zum letzten mal
beschäftigt haben deshalb seit gerne
wieder dabei und bis dahin tschüss